president Trump's turn in his
impeachment trial after listening to the
Democrats make their case over three
days about why the president should be
removed from office his legal team will
get their first chance today they will
start to respond to the two articles
that define the president's impeachment
abuse of power and obstruction of
Congress and they're expected to address
the Democrats push for witnesses and
additional documents we Jiujiang is at
the White House we do what are we
expecting to hear from the president's
team today oh good morning Dana and good
morning to everybody the president's
legal team will give America a sneak
peek of their case before getting into
the quote nitty-gritty on Monday they
will argue the president did nothing
wrong that this is all a political act
and they will attack Joe and Hunter
Biden to make the point that President
Trump was justified in calling to
investigate them now the White House
follows House Democrats who made a
passionate plea for more witnesses and
evidence they say to preserve what this
country stands for give America a fair
trial give America a fair trial she's
worth it with that House Democrats
closed their case against President
Trump late last night as they seek to
remove him from office today the
president's legal team will begin laying
out his defense led by white House
Counsel Patsy Bologna and the
president's personal lawyer Jay Sekulow
we're gonna refute the allegations that
they've made we're gonna put on an
affirmative case as well this has been a
very painful period mr. Trump's
attorneys are brushing off a new
recording reviewed by ABC News the
president appears to say quote get rid
of then US ambassador to Ukraine Murray
Jovanovic at a private dinner at the
Trump Hotel in April of 2018 a full year
before she was removed
ABC reports this recording capture some
of the president's party guests
including former White House aide John
de Stefano and two now indicted
Associates of Rudy Giuliani Igor Froman
and left Parnas but mr. Trump insists he
does not know Parnas he's a con man I
don't know and late last night he denied
ever talking about firing Jovanovic at
that dinner while defending her removal
I want ambassadors that are chosen by me
I have a right to hire and fire
ambassadors on his July 25th phone call
with ukrainian President Vladimir's
Olinsky he called Jovanovic bad news and
said she's going to go through some
things he never explained why I was
shocked absolutely shocked and
devastated frankly Democrats are seeking
to include more evidence and testimony
from key witnesses during the trial and
a new Reuters poll suggests seven in ten
Americans agree they also want to hear
from witnesses who were blocked from
testifying by the White House during the
house proceedings
president Trump complained about the
timing of his team's opening arguments
describing Saturday as TV's quote death
valley well with no public scheduled
public events on his schedule and
whether that is too rainy for golf guys
I think it's fair to say that the
President himself will be upping those
ratings Jeff the latest numbers say
otherwise but we gia and mr. president
thank you very much
graduations guys thank you very much we
shut